(Corea del Sur, años 50. Después de más
de tres décadas de colonización japonesa,
de la división del país en dos y de tres años
de guerra fratricida, el país estaba destrozado.
Para colmo, casi toda la industria,
la minería y el 80 % de la producción
eléctrica que existían cuando Corea se
partió en dos en 1948 se concentraban
en la parte norte. Corea del Sur nació
siendo un país extremadamente pobre.
En los años 50 su PIB per cápita era inferior
al de países como Haití, Etiopía o Yemen.)
El primer presidente surcoreano Syngman Rhee
lideró algunas reformas, como la agraria o la
creación de un sistema educativo de relativamente
alta calidad. Pero eso no era suficiente.
La economía surcoreana dependía básicamente
una agricultura rudimentaria y de la ayuda
internacional de socios como Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo, un momento porque, de repente, eso
empezó a cambiar. En cuestión de pocas décadas,
Corea del Sur sería un país
completamente diferente.
Es algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado en pasados
vídeos, Corea del Sur es hoy en día uno de los
países más ricos y avanzados tecnológicamente de
todo el mundo. Hablamos de un líder industrial de
primer nivel. Y no importa si hablamos de acero,
coches o barcos. Corea es, incluso, una potencia
en semiconductores, el petróleo del siglo XXI.
Las empresas coreanas son capaces de fabricar
semiconductores tan avanzados que ni siquiera
los Estados Unidos pueden hacer algo igual.
Y todo eso por no hablar de los rascacielos,
el K-pop o hasta las series de Netflix.
Y sí, tal y como seguramente muchos
os estéis imaginando, esta es una
de esas historias que tienen un personaje
principal, una figura absolutamente clave.
(En 1961 la situación económica de Corea
del Sur seguía sin mejorar demasiado,
y la corrupción y el descontento
social crecían como la espuma.
Al final toda esta irritación social terminó
explotando con un golpe de Estado militar que
en ese momento muchos apoyaron porque pensaban
que así se lograría algo de estabilidad.
De esta forma, el General Park Chung Hee derrocó
al gobierno del recién electo primer ministro
Chang Myon, e instauró un gobierno militar
reformista dirigido por él mismo. Park Chung
Hee se convirtió en presidente todopoderoso en
1962. Su larga dictadura que duraría 18 años.)
Y, ojo, porque cuando hablamos de gobierno
militar reformista nos referimos a que
esta dictadura tenía una obsesión por encima de
cualquier otra: industria, industria e industria.
Park estaba convencido de
que solo así el país podría
escapar de la pobreza. Pero para
conseguirlo hacía falta un plan.
¿Queréis saber que fue lo que hizo? ¿Hasta
qué punto se lograron cambiar las cosas en
Corea? ¿Es acaso este el mejor modelo posible
para países que quieran escapar de la pobreza?
Pues… De algo estamos seguros es de que toda
esta historia os va a sorprender y mucho.
[Y por cierto, un apunte importante: si estáis
buscando contenido diferente aquí en YouTube,
quedaos hasta el final del vídeo porque tenemos
una recomendación muy especial de nuestros amigos
de Planet Wild que realizan proyectos para cambiar
el mundo a mejor y no os los podéis perder.]
(EL NACIMIENTO DE UNA ESTRELLA INDUSTRIAL)
Hace algunos años, en un pasado
vídeo aquí en VisualPolitik ya
os dimos algunas pinceladas sobre
el desarrollo de Corea del Sur. Un
modelo que no tiene nada que ver con
las típicas recetas de libre mercado,
inversión extranjera y bajos impuestos
de las que normalmente os solemos hablar.
En Corea del Sur durante un tiempo las cosas se
hicieron de una forma un poco diferente. Ahora
bien, la pregunta que todos estáis esperando
es, pero, ¿qué fue exactamente lo que se hizo?
Pues bien, según la mayoría analistas
podemos identificar al menos 3 fases:
(La primera fase fue la que corresponde a la
política de sustitución de importaciones. Esta
política fue la impulsada por el presidente
Rhee desde que terminó la guerra de Corea en
1953 hasta la llegada al poder de Park en 1961.
Básicamente, consistía en tratar de impulsar la
economía sustituyendo productos importados por
otros hechos en Corea del Sur. No funcionó.
La segunda fase fue la de la industrialización
orientada a las exportaciones, o la del Estado
desarrollista, que fue la que se llevó
a cabo durante la dictadura de Park.
Y por último estaría la fase de equilibrio
y estabilización, que se considera que
comenzó en los años 80 y que llega hasta el
periodo actual. En esta fase se abrió el mercado
surcoreano con una liberalización progresiva
y se fomentó la inversión extranjera directa.)
Ahora bien, un momento. Park…
¿Estado desarrollista? ¿Qué
demonios es eso del estado desarrollista?
Pues veréis, lo que se conoce como estado
desarrollista es un sistema político y
económico bastante común entre los países
emergentes de Asia y África. Básicamente,
consiste en intentar promover el desarrollo
económico a través de la industrialización.
¿Os acordáis de lo que decíamos de
industria, industria e industria? Pues eso.
Pero claro, hablar de industrialización es fácil…
Es como si yo digo que me gustaría convertirme
de repente en ingeniero cuántico. Lo difícil,
por supuesto, es lograrlo. Así que la pregunta
es, ¿Qué demonios hicieron los surcoreanos?
Pues… Básicamente dopar la
industria. Cebarla todo lo
posible y más mientras al mismo tiempo
se restringían las importaciones. Para
el régimen de Park Chung Hee todo
lo demás daba absolutamente igual:
Ni bienestar social, ni subsidios
a la gente, ni nada por el estilo.
Prácticamente, todos los recursos disponibles se
dirigieron a la industria. El estado apoyaba que
las empresas crecieran. A cambio estas tenías
que invertir y exportar todo lo que pudieran.
La idea era que con empresas fuertes
y una industria desarrollada,
la riqueza terminaría inundando
todos los estratos de la sociedad.
Ahora bien, todo esto suena muy
bonito y, aparentemente, muy fácil,
pero no olvidéis que os acabamos de
contar que Corea del Sur era un país
extremadamente pobre y que el Estado dependía
esencialmente de las ayudas internacionales.
Entonces… ¿Cómo diantres se podía impulsar
la industria con semejante panorama?
Pues veréis, aquí estuvo una de las jugadas
clave. Para conseguir el dinero, lo primero
que hizo el régimen de Park fue idear un sistema
en el que era el estado quien buscaba financiación
por todo el mundo y luego se la entregaba a las
empresas con préstamos artificialmente baratos.
De esta forma, el gobierno surcoreano solo cargaba
con el coste de los intereses, al tiempo que se
aseguraba que las empresas surcoreanas tuvieran
todo el dinero que necesitaban para crecer.
Esta financiación vino fundamentalmente
de dos lugares: Estados Unidos y Japón.
Pero, ¿Queréis un dato? Pues veréis,
tan solo en la década que transcurre
entre los años 1972 y 1982 la
deuda externa creció en términos
absolutos un 825 %. Pasó de unos 4 mil
millones de dólares a más de 37 mil.
Claro que como la industria ya estaba comenzando a
exportar y el despegue económico estaba comenzando
gracias a ello, los pagos de la deuda en
relación a la riqueza del país apenas crecieron.
Aunque eso sí, no todo el dinero
se consiguió con préstamos.
También hubo parte que se consiguió a través de
la diplomacia. Concretamente en 1965 el presidente
Park negoció y firmó el Tratado de Relaciones
Básicas entre Japón y la República de Corea.
Gracias a este tratado, el país del anime,
el sushi y el Origami le entregó a Corea
del Sur 800 millones de dólares de
la época en forma de subvenciones
y préstamos a bajos intereses, como
reparaciones por su pasado colonial.
Y ojo que no era poco dinero. Esos 800 millones
equivalían a más del 20% de todo
el PIB surcoreano de aquel año.
Y la pregunta es, ¿qué pensáis que hizo el
gobierno surcoreano con todo este dinero? Pues
hizo exactamente lo mismo que hizo con el dinero
que pedía prestado en el mercado internacional:
entregárselo a las empresas para que
estas construyeran la industria nacional.
(Para repartir el dinero, el gobierno
confió sobre todo en un grupo de
familias de empresarios que ya habían hecho
negocios en Corea, en Japón y otros países.
La idea es que a estas familias no les faltará
el dinero para levantar su imperio. Un imperio
que funcionaría de forma totalmente privada
y autónoma en el día a día, pero que eso sí,
a cambio, tenían que cumplir los objetivos
de producción establecidos por el gobierno.)
Y así es, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, como
se crearon los chaebols, los grandes conglomerados
empresariales que producían prácticamente de todo.
Hablamos de gigantes como el Grupo Samsung, el
Grupo Hyundai o el Grupo Lotte que durante décadas
fueron tremendamente favorecidas por el estado.
Y cuando decimos que fabrican prácticamente
de todo lo decimos en muy en serio:
Samsung fabrica aires acondicionados,
smartphones, televisores, microchips,
frigoríficos… Por producir produce hasta barcos.
Por ejemplo, para que os hagáis una idea de lo
que estamos hablando, tan solo el Grupo Samsung
todavía representa, atención, el 20 % del PIB
surcoreano. Sí, lo sé, es una auténtica locura.
(Otro buen ejemplo es el grupo POSCO, que
fue el Chaebol que más dinero recibió de las
reparaciones japonesas. Ni más ni menos que 100
de los 800 millones de dólares pagados por Tokio
terminaron en esta compañía. Con ese dinero POSCO
construyó enormes y modernas plantas de acero,
lo que junto a los bajos salarios hizo que
fuese muy competitiva. El resultado es que
casi 60 años después POSCO es todavía el sexto
mayor fabricante de acero a nivel mundial.)
Curioso, ¿No os parece? Seguro que alguno
habéis pensado en la Unión Soviética. Y en
cierto modo es normal: en Corea del Sur el
gobierno tenía planes quinquenales y fijaba
los objetivos de producción. Sin embargo,
la gran diferencia es que en Corea nunca
tuvieron intención de que los medios de
producción fueran estatales. De hecho,
el sector privado y, sobre todo, estos
chaebols tuvieron bastante manga ancha.
(En una primera etapa, las inversiones se
dirigieron a industrias relativamente simples
y fáciles de establecer. Sin embargo, a
medida que estas comenzaban a producir,
el estado financiaba el desarrollo de
producciones cada vez más complejas. Y
así del acero se pasó a los coches y a los
barcos, y de estos a la electrónica. Y así
sucesivamente. Era la construcción de una
inmensa cadena de producción made in Korea.)
Pero ahí no termina todo.
Al mismo tiempo, el gobierno también apoyó
la apertura al comercio exterior, eso sí,
de forma fundamentalmente unidireccional.
Es decir, de Corea para el mundo,
pero no al revés. La idea era convertirse en una
megafábrica para el resto del planeta, al tiempo
que se obligaba a los surcoreanos a consumir
sus propios productos en el mercado nacional.
En la práctica, el gobierno solo daba
vía libre para comprar en el extranjero
aquellos productos que necesitara la
propia industria nacional. Nada más.
Pero quizás lo más llamativo es que
para lograr impulsar las exportaciones,
el estado hizo prácticamente de todo:
no solo daba financiación barata,
también un montón de ayudas
fiscales y regulatorias.
Por ejemplo, las empresas que exportaban tenían
todo tipo de beneficios: reducciones en el
impuesto sobre beneficios, exenciones de
aranceles, préstamos en divisa extranjera y hasta
un seguro de exportación costeado por el estado.
Y no solo eso: ¿Que necesitaban construir
una fábrica nueva o una carretera? No
había problema, el estado se ocupaba de las
expropiaciones y de todo lo que hiciera falta.
Barra libre a cambio de
invertir, producir y exportar.
(Estos privilegios los podemos ver perfectamente
si echamos un vistazo a los tipos de interés
subvencionado. En 1965, por ejemplo,
mientras que los préstamos se daban a
tipos del 26% los préstamos a las empresas de
exportación tenían un coste de apenas un 6,5%.
Estos préstamos eran conocidos como “préstamos
políticos” y fundamentalmente eran otorgados
por el Banco Industrial de Corea y por el
Banco de Desarrollo de Corea, dos entidades
financieros de propiedad estatal. De hecho, los
chaebols llegaron a recibir, incluso, préstamos
con interés negativo. Es decir, que los bancos
públicos les pagaban por prestarles dinero.)
Y todavía no hemos terminado. El gobierno de
Park también depreciaba en la medida de lo
posible el Won, la moneda nacional, para que
fuera más barato comprar desde el extranjero.
Y sí, ya sé lo que estáis
pensando… ¡Qué barbaridad,
eso destruye la riqueza! Y es verdad,
pero también tiene otro efecto que en
ese momento era totalmente prioritario para
la dictadura: ayudaba a exportar más barato.
En cierta forma, esto funcionaba como
una transferencia del bolsillo de los
surcoreanos a los grandes grupos exportadores
del país. Por así decirlo, se mermaba el poder
adquisitivo de los surcoreanos a cambio
de enriquecer a los grandes conglomerados.
Claro que ese no fue el único sacrificio.
Los trabajadores surcoreanos también
tuvieron que lidiar con incrementos
de salarios que estaban muy por debajo
de los incrementos de productividad.
¿Por qué? Pues para evitar a toda
costa que los costes se disparasen.
Eso explica por qué los chaebols se hicieron
cada vez más y más importantes dentro de la
economía nacional. Lo tenían todo a su favor.
Y sí, ya imagino lo que estaréis pensando…
¡Menudo sistema más injusto! Pues sí, pero
al menos consiguieron una cosa: redujeron mucho la
pobreza. La gente dejó de trabajar en el campo y
pasó a trabajar en fábricas que aunque pagaban mal
les hacía ganar más dinero que plantando patatas.
De esta forma, si en 1965 más del 40% de la
población era considerada pobre de solemnidad,
este porcentaje se redujo hasta el 9,8% en 1981.
Por supuesto, todo esto promovió un
enorme éxodo de población del campo a
la ciudad. En las zonas rurales las tasas de
pobreza eran muchísimo más altas. Pues bien,
aquí nos encontramos con otro de los grandes
iconos del despegue de Corea: el Saemaul Undong,
que traducido al español significaría
algo así como Movimiento Nueva Aldea.
(Esta fue una iniciativa lanzada por Park en
1970 con el objetivo de modernizar la Corea
rural que seguía siendo terriblemente pobre. En
este caso, en lugar de darles dinero o decidir
desde el gobierno central qué tenían o no que
hacer en las áreas rurales para salir adelante,
lo que hizo el gobierno fue entregarles
una cantidad fija y regular de materiales
de construcción. Las comunidades
decidían qué hacer con ellos y a
las que mejor aprovechasen los recursos
se les premiaba con materiales extra.)
El éxito fue tal que todavía a día de hoy, 53 años
después de su creación, este movimiento sigue en
cierto modo existiendo y, de hecho, Corea del Sur
lo intenta exportar como modelo a países pobres.
("Con la difusión de Saemaul Undong, estamos
ayudando a las naciones en desarrollo a confiar en
la prosperidad al compartir nuestra experiencia de
desarrollo económico". Expresidente Moon Jae In)
Básicamente, la idea era la siguiente: no
les des peces, dales las cañas de pescar.
Pero, anécdotas aparte, como
ocurre con todas las dictaduras,
ni todo es tan bonito como
parece ni duran para siempre.
El presidente Park Chung Hee fue asesinado el 26
de octubre de 1979 por el director de la KCIA,
el servicio secreto surcoreano, durante
una cena privada. Claro que el país
continuó bajo las riendas de una dictadura
militar hasta principios de los años 90.
[Sí, la democracia surcoreana es mucho
más joven de lo que te podías imaginar.]
El caso es que en lo que respecta a la economía,
las décadas de los 80 y los 90 sí que trajeron
consigo muchos cambios. Entre otras cosas porque
el modelo de Park tuvo también muchos problemas:
La competencia brillaba por su ausencia, las
empresas eran terriblemente dependiente de los
bajos costes laborales, los tipos de cambio
depreciados y las ayudas del gobierno. Muchas
inversiones no eran del todo productivas
y la falta de innovación era un problema.
Digamos que las empresas surcoreanas
sabían copiar, pero tenían muchos más
problemas para crear. Y eso no es todo, por
supuesto, las condiciones de vida en el país
eran peores de lo que correspondía
a su nivel de desarrollo económico.
En general, escapar de la pobreza es mucho
más fácil que escapar de la llamada trampa
de los ingresos medios. De hecho,
es posible que Corea del Sur fuese
hoy más rica de no haber aplicado tan a
rajatabla el modelo instaurado por Park.
Sin ir más lejos, en la comparación con los
otros tigres asiáticos no sale tan bien parada.
Y exactamente por este motivo los
gobiernos posteriores a Park y,
especialmente, los gobiernos democráticos,
han hecho muchas reformas para acabar con
los Chaebols y abrir el país a la competencia
y a la inversión extranjera. ¿Y sabéis qué?
Eso ha funcionado aún mejor.
Fijaos en este otro gráfico:
Lo que estáis viendo es la
inversión extranjera directa en Corea del Sur
respecto al producto interior bruto. Cómo veis,
a medida que el país abandonó el proteccionismo,
los capitales extranjeros comenzaron a llegar
como si no hubiera mañana. Y con la apertura
las empresas surcoreanas tuvieron también que
apostar mucho más por la innovación. De
hecho, sin la creciente apertura de los años
80 y 90 es muy probable que la industria
surcoreana se hubiera quedado muy atrás.
Pero si algo está claro es que pese a
todo el proceso de industrialización fue
un tremendo éxito. Pasar de una economía
agraria a una economía industrial siempre
supone un gran salto adelante. También
ocurrió en la propia Unión Soviética. La
diferencia es que en Corea apostaron porque la
iniciativa la tuvieran las empresas privadas y
no el estado y eso fue decisivo… Pero como
veis tampoco arregló todos los problemas.
[Y llegados hasta aquí como lo prometido
es deuda, queremos recomendaros un canal
de protección medioambiental que nos ha encantado.
Planet Wild es un proyecto único porque nos enseña
cómo podemos proteger el medioambiente con unos
vídeos sencillamente espectaculares y educativos.
Planet Wild es una comunidad global de personas
que quieren mejorar el mundo financiando proyectos
trascendentes de protección medioambiental. Tú
también puedes unirte si crees que es el momento
de actuar y proteger el planeta. Nosotros ya
formamos parte de esta comunidad porque nos
parece una forma revolucionaria de generar un
impacto positivo visible en nuestro entorno.
Sus vídeos os van a encantar, porque aprendes
al mismo tiempo que disfrutas. Hay dos vídeos
que me han gustado especialmente y me gustaría
recomendaros: uno sobre el mochuelo europeo,
un pequeño ave rapaz que siempre
he encontrado adorable y que por
desgracia se encuentra en peligro
de extinción; y otro en el que están
restaurando el ecosistema de un río tras
la repentina muerte de millones de peces
en un desastre ecológico. Échales un vistazo
y compruébalo por ti mismo. Os va a encantar.